so the scene down here and you can
probably see it over my shoulder the car
that driving to the gates of Downing
Street is still there there are a number
of police outside some of them are
standing near to the cordons some of
them it seems are going through the car
meticulously I think trying to just
check it all over that's the scene at
the moment Whitehall is still shut down
from here up to Parliament Square
there are as you can imagine lots of
people Milling around here there are
lots of tourists here as they usually
are there's huge amount of press here
when I was coming down here there were a
number of police cars with flashing
lights rushing down to Downing Street it
does seem at the moment that things have
calmed down a little bit the expectation
is I think that
quite soon this road will be opened up
we don't know in terms of who was in the
building in Downing street where the
prime minister is at at the moment I can
tell you that because recess is coming
quite soon a lot of the MPS aren't here
so
Westminster itself is not full of
ministers and MPS as it usually would be
so that's really the scene down here at
the moment I think what was quite clear
when I was coming down here was that
this isn't a situation where all of
Westminster is locked down Parliament
itself security seems to be at the same
level they're still letting people in
and out this incident seems to be quite
contained
to outside Downing Street and as we've
already reported this was just one
arrest of one man and now that we've
seen the footage it's quite clear that
um well it seems that this wasn't a sort
of uh very aggressive attack you can see
yourself the car sort of meandered over
almost into the gates of Downing Street
I think what's happening at the moment
is the police have shut everything down
they're assessing the situation it
doesn't seem that the security has been
ramped up across Westminster and I think
the expectation is that if anything
things will start to get back to normal
quite soon